today we're gonna be reading paranormal
campus activity stories and I personally
have never had a paranormal experience
and I hope I never have one I think I
saw a ghost when I was younger on
Halloween what my brother's girlfriend
and I were at my house for Thanksgiving
and we just saw one of our cups move
across the table and my dad was like
didn't believe us so he went and like
measured the table cuz he was like
you're tricking us and it was completely
flat I'm not saying it's paranormal but
it was something the first story is the
room in Trinity Hall I go to Texas
Lutheran and supposedly a girl died in
one of the rooms in Trinity Hall ever
since then her room has been closed off
and no one is allowed in except a
Residence Life staff one day I heard a
ton of banging above my room and called
my RA we went upstairs and maintenance
opened the door we saw a very human leg
scratch and blood lookin stains all over
the walls the ceiling was completely
black and there was about an inch of
water on the floor and dripping down the
walls totally unexplainable I feel like
I have a lot of questions right now the
next one was the little girl in the
mirror who I don't like this already I
went to the second-oldest Seminary in
the country which used to be a civil war
hospital one night I had a dream of a
little girl laughing at me in the
bathroom looking out at me from the
mirror when I woke up I was no longer in
bed but standing in the bathroom in
front of a mirror sounds very like
paranormal activity like Annabelle asked
great movies the dark crawling figure I
lived in wells Hall at the University of
Wisconsin which is considered the most
haunted dorm on campus it was around 3
a.m. when I looked over at my roommate
and saw a dark figure crawl out from
under her bed and then crawled back
under I was nearly in tears and couldn't
breathe because I was so terrified yeah
this one wouldn't make me cry for sure
oh my god first of all I would ask for a
transfer immediately the children with
black eyes I was awoken in the middle of
the night by the sound of kids playing
and talking
it was dark but I saw two kids sitting
on my roommates bed they turned to look
at me and the eyes were all black I
don't know what happened after that I
think I fainted because my roommate
found me lying on the floor in the
morning I rented an apartment nearby
after that incident yeah I would totally
get out too I would have also fainted
I feel like sounds of kids playing is
totally so freaky like it's like one of
those things that you would think is so
pleasant but the unexplained scratches I
live in one of the older dorms on campus
and my roommates and I have always heard
rustling sounds
we searched the room to see if we could
find some kind of animal or source of
the noise but we didn't find anything
later on that night I was writing a
paper and out of nowhere two scratches
appeared on my arm whoa the scratches
burned for about five minutes and then
stopped I still live in the dorm and I
found new unexplainable scratches on my
body almost every day since then if I
was this girl I would just move out the
door simple that's a simple solution
don't know why she's still in there kind
of dumb the upside-down pictures my room
and I would convinced that a room was
haunted things would always fall off our
walls in the middle of the night and for
no reason at all sometimes we'd come
back after classes and some of our
pictures on the wall would be upside
down we couldn't come to a reasonable
explanation for any of it yeah that's
really that's no the first time the
pictures fell off the wall maybe they
just did a bad job putting it on the
wall I'm glad she has a roommate because
at least they can go through it together
long story short don't live in an old
dorm I think I believe them because they
have no explanation if there was a big
reason behind it it'd be kind of
modified fabricated
if I encountered where these experiences
oh I would run away I would get out like
the girl that changed apartments good
for her because I that's me
I would like move so far away I'm yeah I
don't know I probably would reconsider
okay maybe I'm not a skeptic but also
I'd be like if I die I die you know life
goes on or not I guess if you die so
that's what I would do